hey guys Mary here with GameSpot
presents the mix at e3 2015 I'm here
with Shawn from White Rabbit absolutely
yes hey thanks for being here and you're
here to show us deaths gambit this game
I've actually heard rumors about you
don't often see that right you always
like maybe see a trailer or something
but I've actually heard developer rumors
people are so curious that your game
that they're talking about it so I'm
really stoked to take a look at it so
let's get right into it you tell me I've
been told this is kind of a viewer
saying this is kind of inspired by a
Dark Souls feel it's not a game but you
tell me a little bit more about it yeah
it's like definitely like this
Castlevania ish Dark Souls ish dark kind
of Colossus game if you look at our
trailer you see all the really difficult
again all the games with crazy boss
fights and 2d make it into like this 2d
like action RPG platformer it does have
like a lot of RPG elements so you can
see see see here right now it's like
pretty technics fire but it also has you
know heavy slow weapons you know it's
all about timing your attacks but yeah
it's all about exploring this nonlinear
world you go find like what is the next
boss you get a beat and get stronger get
gear whenever you fight a boss you get
gear and depending how you beat him you
actually get different items okay I can
see right in the lower left here you got
a bow and sword but what's that below
that so below that actually are some
abilities so and you're kind of like a
toolkit is you have two weapon slots and
ability slots and oh yeah this guy's
strong yes so the ability slots on the
bottom you can equip them at a safe
point okay and those you can find from
the world you can get that while killing
bosses and for merchants as well okay
and so also one of our main mechanics
really is when you die in this game you
might happen no hopefully not so we can
show the full demo well yeah but the
Phoenix feathers drop so those are your
healing items okay you know in the souls
games we have a splash yes but here is
Phoenix feathers and those are your
pretty much your only way to
okay and is it in the system then where
your you can obtain more flasks and it's
a huge deal right now you can travel
further exactly and it's even bigger
deal because the save points at same
points you can actually choose to have
less healing items for more damage so
it's kind of a risk reward a factor of
man do I want to go with less heals or
do I want yeah last heals for more
damage
well actually it's really good for some
boss battles you know if you're like
actually I think I can dodge everything
I just need more damage let's go okay it
looks like you're gonna have a wide
range of enemies here and we've just yes
started and I've already seen probably
like six or seven new enemies yeah you
know encounters ever the same okay well
in the sense that like each like like as
you progress towards a boss you will see
there is another unique enemy you know
we don't want the player to you know
keep repeating the same models the same
like combat scenarios how many different
areas have you made in this game well
the one that we've shown right now is
Alduin we haven't really revealed how
many areas we developed so far oh yeah
this is pretty much all kinds of areas
there's this ice area called obsidian
plateau as well as some I will say very
surprising elements of I will say sci-fi
that I can't really get into it it's not
all medieval at all for here and so as I
was saying ya know the healing is real
important because when you die you have
to go pick up your healing at him yeah
and now what can you do volge about the
story at all like what are we doing here
yeah for sure
so the one thing that we really revealed
is that it begins when your character is
that the verge of his at the victory of
his demise you know kind of like right
now but he's at the verge of his death
and death himself comes to him he offers
him solve a ssin in exchange for doing a
mission for him which actually involves
killing immortals because that doesn't
like immortal he wants people to die
yeah we all die he's just tired Lee
these guys I just don't want to die so
that is basically what we reveal so far
and this is the journey of you
complaining
that's mission that he gave you yeah as
you can see I will I will mention the
depressions playing the demo has played
this far many times like everyone seeing
a little bit of just how much difficulty
can be in this game and that's not to
deter people because difficulty is what
makes you appreciate the game so much I
mean anyone who's a fan of the Dark
Souls series like absolutely what makes
it so good is when you actually do end
up beating like the horses chair it is
just like yes I feel amazing about
yourself and then you quit you go to
sleep like when I play games like these
I actually have calm down games that I
play for half-hour before I go to sleep
because I get so angry and excited that
I can't I can't actually like relax so
it seems like it's in that same vein
you've really done a good job at
creating you know anxiety but then also
reward for that so I just a the player
who's gonna show you a boss right now
actually real quick this looks Tundra
Lord yeah so we want all our bosses to
have like at least one unique mechanic
that's never like you know that makes it
stand out so this one takes place in a
platform that is moving side to side and
depending on where both characters are
the weight will like shift that way you
have to be really careful so see the
main characters moving to the left side
huh
so that he can shift the weight will it
keep rotating until you it'll fall it'll
actually fall yep else you fall you both
fall and you're both died but the boss
is immortal so he'll come back so that's
this part of the main story you know
figure out what happens because he's
positive mortal like how do you make
progress you know and this is something
that it will be consistent right so with
other boss fights there might be other
oh yeah and environmental yeah issues or
or is something maybe that might come to
your advantage
yes and as you saw have you seen our
trailer there's many climbing bosses so
you have to like there's very large
bosses you have like a hook-shot that
you like climb around with uh-huh and so
you're about to see some or like there
in the trailer you will see some very
cool like shadow causes style and how do
you is it is a linear progression know
the whole world
you just go wherever you want some
someplace that are definitely too strong
at the start though but yeah all right
that's figure it out by trial and error
I mean if you're really hardcore you
could go over the for the really tough
ones to start out you get rewarded for
that if you did try to push your luck
early on I mean you'll get really good
items from a start
yeah but that being said you know we've
designed there we did it we actually
designed the early bosses to you know
even if you come in with some really
good gear they'll still pose some
challenges yeah there's only so much
that these items can't help you like
sure maybe you fall here it looks like
it's more skill-based there's certain
bosses that you're like role techniques
aggression like you were saying before
maybe not have so many heels and go for
straight damage and just try to get it
over as quick as possible also exactly
lots of different tactics that you'll
basically just die until you figure it
out yeah and there you go yep
it looks like up there you go this is
where we come back yep yeah when you do
die where do you spawn use your safe
point late a safe point yeah it's not
too cruel then it's not - no but we made
our bosses definitely really challenging
to take for the fact that a safe went
out right next to the bosses okay well
sweet thank you so much for showing us
that that was deaths gambit so be sure
to take a look at that when you can and
be sure to stay tuned to games.com for
all your game needs
you